kabul in august last year as the taliban
took over afghans scrambled to be
airlifted out
among them were staff and animals from
the charity now zad run by former marine
pen farthing who left from the city's
airport on a privately chartered plane
the prime minister has denied any
involvement in authorizing this
evacuation but today a serving senior
official here at the foreign office who
worked on the afghan operation became
the second government whistleblower to
contradict boris johnson in evidence to
the foreign affairs committee josie
stewart wrote i feel a strong sense of
moral injury for having been part of
something so badly managed and so
focused on managing reputational risk
and political fallout rather than the
actual crisis and associated human
tragedy and on the charity operation it
was widespread knowledge that the
decision on nausea's afghan staff came
from the prime minister
ms stewart also said she believed these
two top officials had lied when they
said they could not find emails stating
boris johnson had authorized the nausea
airlift a point put to them by mps on
the foreign affairs committee today i
don't understand why other people could
find this emails and you couldn't well
it's possible that i had deleted the
emails my email box was was exploding
and it is quite possible that i weeded
out other emails which were copied to me
the foreign office's top civil servant
said the emails were based on an
incorrect assumption that boris johnson
was involved and he didn't know to this
day who authorized the evacuation you
said that i think it was the primary
decision i i don't think that i don't
know
i
find it difficult to believe you
nigel we can only we can we've been 90
minutes
number 10 has again denied boris johnson
had any involvement or that animals were
put before humans the foreign secretary
at the time dominic raab was moved from
the department last year amid criticism
of his handling of the crisis the prime
minister was directly involved he
supported the project from the beginning
and he did authorize the visas for
nasa's staff and family members to come
out and to allow that aircraft to enter
into the airspace at kabul airport to
take the animals and people out of the
country the prime minister was under
huge pressure he had to do something he
intervened in my view for the right
reasons
amid chaos in kabul today's
whistleblower testimony paints a picture
of chaos at the foreign office as well
more concern over how government was
functioning at a moment of crisis for so
many rob powell sky news